procrastinators you know it's crunch
time now the cash register is expected
to go crazy as we wrap up the holiday
season despite concerns about the
omicron variant hector mejia live from
decatur and charleston where a walmart
just opened about half an hour ago
hector how's it going out there
now we're starting to see a few more
shoppers making their way into the store
here at this walmart you know while
retailers take almost an entire year of
planning for the holiday season
a lot of us still wait for the last
minute and over at amazon today december
23rd is the last day prime members can
order one day delivery the online giant
will deliver delivered through december
24th and just yesterday the fulfillment
center up in north las vegas was so busy
it sent out over 700 000 customer orders
in a single day we're told that's 50
percent more packages than usual for the
company
we spend 10 months out of the year
preparing for the holiday season we can
confidently say even
a part of las vegas like the strip we're
going to get the packages to our
customers when they need it and where
they need it
the facility we went to sorts items
swaying 25 pounds or less and those get
sent over to the delivery stations
across the valley and to keep up with
demand around the valley amazon had to
staff up hiring 15 000 local employees
just in 2020 and the national retail
federation expects record growth
expecting an 11 percent increase in
holiday sales this year compared to last
year reporting live hector mejia live
local now